[Musique]
c'est l'heure du conseil de votre
journaliste à la recherche les fraudes
en ligne se répandent comme une épidémie
vous pensez en être victime ou témoin
notre équipe vous prescrit une visite
sur le site de fraude alertes.ca pour
une thérapie élaborée par la clinique de
cybercriminologie de l'Université de
Montréal pour atteindre l'immunité
collective l'union fait la force tous
les consommateurs touchés sont invités à
faire un signalement il y en a déjà plus
de 5000 ils sont répertoriés par
catégorie mais vous pouvez aussi faire
une recherche précise avec un numéro de
téléphone un nom ou une adresse courriel
vous aurez de bonnes chances
d'identifier un des nombreux variants
auxquels vous avez été exposés fraude
d'alerte.ca vous permet aussi de
consulter un spécialiste de la clinique
de cybercriminologie pour des conseils
personnalisés attention nos journalistes
à la recherche vous rappelle que ce site
ne remplace pas les autorités si vous
êtes victime d'une fraude signalez-la
mais contactez aussi la police le centre
antipode du Canada et l'Office ou
l'autorité de la protection du
consommateur de votre province passez le
mot
[Musique]